[Music]
oh
[Applause]
we brought together seven black belts i
am a black belt i'm a black belt i'm a
black belt i am a black belt i'm a black
belt i'm a black belt i am a black belt
two of them are liars if the group
discovers both liars they'll split a
cash prize
if any of the liars survives they win
the entire prize
who is the odd one now
[Music]
i guess we'll do it real quick because
it's the most generic thing how long
everybody's been training what your
martial art is we can just go straight
on the line my name is andre i've been
training for eight years i do taekwondo
i'm jessica and i also do taekwondo for
about a decade more than that my name's
keith hudson and i've been training for
six years now in karate and taekwondo my
name is victoria i've been training for
like over 10 years now and i do kaji
kimbo i came on here to like bring
representation to the style adriana been
doing it for like 15 years
taekwondo third degree my name is casey
i have been doing hopkido for nine years
my name is anthony cruz and i've been
doing jiu jitsu for about 10 years a lot
of taekwondo people huh yeah
well you're all into martial arts i
played a lot of fighting games as a kid
hidden stuff
one day i kicked the table mother was
furious she was like we have to take
this energy somewhere else and the next
day she enrolled me and i going to do
gym when we were all in line andre was
talking to himself and i think he was
going over his head to make sure he's
not going to miss a cue a lot of jackie
chan growing up and i was like i want to
join like karate like what not kung fu
my dad was a black belt i got
indoctrinated when i was five go my dad
put me in it to like learn self defense
my dad did aikido when i was younger and
i said that i wanted to be like him dad
didn't want to want me to be a ballerina
so that's why he put me in hopkinton i
loved mma and the ufc i would have a
better understanding of it so i got into
igitsu
a little too specific with the lamp
story which is kind of a dead giveaway
when people are lying
i felt like anthony was suspicious
because the way he was like instigating
the conversation
[Music]
i'm gonna talk fighting games with you
later
this is round two the martial arts round
you will each have about 30 seconds to
demonstrate your martial arts and prove
to the others that you are a black belt
i'm not gonna throw it don't worry okay
all right all right
oh
[Applause]
that was so bad i'm sorry
[Music]
her form seemed kind of like basic and i
thought since she did like taekwondo she
would do like a lot of kicks and stuff
okay so i'm going to talk as if i'm
teaching a normal class can you come
into this is called a garden jiu jitsu
it's one of the most uh it's one of the
martial arts that teaches you how to be
offensive on the ground i'm a teacher is
called a triangle choke and to do a
triangle choke it's a very it's a very
fundamental process but use it from
white to black belt he
showed a jiu jitsu move and it seemed
like very rehearsed and it was something
that anyone could essentially learn that
if they went to a couple classes or
trained a little bit in jiu jitsu boom
and i lock up here and now i have this
my leg across the neck pull the head
down and pitch my hips up and that's it
and if he doesn't tap he goes to sleep
in six seconds
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
permission
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
even though it's super impressive i have
a lot of friends that have learned how
to staff spin saber spin or stunt actors
but they're not black belts
he just did a basic demonstration and he
even used the words everyone uses this
from why belt all the way up to black
belt did i think he did jiu jitsu
absolutely did i think he was a black
belt no
[Music]
[Applause]
i wish i had great hair like that
everyone feels confident that you
already caught them all you can end the
game now but if the majority has doubt
the game will continue please raise your
hand if you want to continue playing the
game
because i have respect for you i i am
the mole
huh
what
i am not a black bell
not yet
but i want to be
and
i don't feel comfortable deceiving any
of you guys
you guys are fantastic and i can't lie i
can't so
i humbly apologize
and i'm sorry for deceiving you guys
is it you guys still have four minutes
okay
i should just do it
i'm just gonna ask like for proper
sidekick technique because that's what i
was getting i hadn't done it in ten
years so honestly i could never even do
as i kicked i kind of suspected it
because you're super martial arts nerd
yeah but like
i know i don't mean that in like a bad
way but i was like he's so nerdy about
it like i feel like he's kind of
fresh-ish so where are you at now yeah
yeah well belter
i just got my first advance belt uh
in the summer uh
i trained during the pandemic i started
training back at martial arts in 2019 i
was a smoker and a drinker through my
20s and
i needed to turn my life around and
oh my god
i wanted to be
honest
i felt it here
this game is fun and i didn't mean to
just you know
just give up but
you guys are so good
and you inspire me and i can't lie to
people who inspire me
[Music]
again we do have
two moles so please raise your hand if
you want to continue playing the game
starting now
for every time all of you vote out
someone that is not the mole the prize
money will be reduced by half
uh the only reason i want to continue is
you did say like i haven't as soon as i
mentioned like sidekick technique i'm
like oh i haven't done it long time so i
don't know honestly i could never even
do if i kicked the form was like a very
basic kind of
color about form and in technology like
in my in my studio it's second degree
wait what's your style though my style
oh shoot like honestly like when it was
never explained to me my master
was never the most professional
i just think when victoria asked you
what style you did it did yeah take a
while to respond because this is right
away oh i do hopkino if you're a black
belt you can easily explain how to do a
sidekick yeah psychic is a basic kick it
is right but my kick was never as good
as i don't know it doesn't it doesn't
matter as long as you can it's like
muscle memory
okay that's good
yeah so the biggest thing is really just
like explaining technique yeah i mean
because like there's people that i've
met that are literally like they're
blind they're paralyzed or whatever and
they can teach and they can explain the
technique down to a tee if that makes
sense no that makes sense so it's just
like it's not to be like offensive or
anything it's just you know what i mean
it's just things that like that we think
of yeah you're like pointing them out
and like um i honestly thought that all
of y'all were like pretty real and i
thought we caught uh andre and keith and
like the guys i thought they were the
moles
you know we're all
professional in a sense
i'm not too sure of victoria's technique
because i'm not i like i don't have any
knowledge of that
i felt bad because like we attacked
jessica but i asked her what martial art
style she did and she like stuttered and
she didn't know and i was like isn't
that why we're here
[Applause]
i'm sorry
i understand it's a game y'all it's a
game please raise your hand if you want
to continue playing the game
if the lights are green that means you
have voted out the mole and you win
if the lights turn red
that means the mole is still in the box
and you lose
[Applause]
[Music]
will the fake black belts
both
please step forward and reveal
yourselves in three
two
one
[Applause]
my dad was a black belt and when we were
young uh he put me in a school in
sherwood arkansas danny drinks living
defense martial arts dojo uh yes i do
martial arts uh
i've like i'm self-taught with like
weapons and everything i do muay thai
like formally that's like the formal
thing that i've done we knew the punches
in the beginning it was uh yes
and i was like
well i didn't want to like
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
and we want to thank you all for
participating and give you all a gift
thank you thank you
[Music]
yes people get surprised when they find
out i'm a black belt i don't really
volunteer the information i love martial
arts i love teaching it i love being
able to spread it it doesn't matter what
age you are what body size you are
anyone can become a black belt as long
as you put the work to it you guys did
make one incorrect vote so i need to
take half
[Music]
[Applause]